cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke rowski join us there get
your tickets by clicking the link in the
description below or by going to
timcast.net
files motion to oust Kevin McCarthy as
house Speaker R Matt Gates introduced a
resolution Monday evening to remove
Kevin McCarthy from his seat triggering
an expected in party Clash and setting
up a showdown for the house to decide
whether to to depose McCarthy likely
within 48 Hours Gates and a handful of
hard right Republicans have repeatedly
threatened to go after McCarthy's
speakership if he relied on Democratic
votes to pass any spending legislation
which happened Saturday after McCarthy
could not get a majority of Republicans
to support various proposals to fund the
government with only GOP votes using a
motion to vacate a single person can
force the house to consider removing the
speaker McCarthy agreed to lowering the
threshold to bring in the motion to win
over enough support to become speaker in
January this one's going to be really
interesting McCarthy is basically a
Democrat at this point if he's now
teaming up with democrats for his
spending bills and working against
Republicans the question though is Will
Democrats now seeing an opportunity team
up with Matt gates to remove Kevin
McCarthy do you guys see what's going on
Twitter right now um Kevin McCarthy just
tweeted quote bringing on bring Bring It
On Matt Gates retweeted him just a
couple minutes ago and said just did so
the drama is unfolding on Twitter in
real time as this video is happening
right now and and it's very interesting
to see what Matt Gates is doing here
because I I I think you know the
long-term strategy for Matt here is to
probably become the next governor of
this very beautiful amazing state after
Rond santis leaves office in a few years
and if he's going to leave in in a fury
of fireworks and just public outrages
and storms this is the way to do it this
is the way to to get your name out there
and in our current kind of political uh
sphere where outrage sells and
controversy really is the lead this is
the way to get everyone's attention and
I think he's doing a good job at it as
of course this is an important issue
he's making an important stand even
though it is Republicans fighting each
other which they usually do anyway I
mean we all knew this was going to
happen right it took McCarthy what 15
votes to get the speakership in the
first place so like it was all leading
to this at some point I think most of us
and probably most of your viewers are
with M with uh gates in spirit of course
like enough of the nonsense spending of
giving all the money away to Ukraine and
everything else like can we take care of
our border uh but I hate to tell Matt
Gates even if this is just because he
wants to be Governor The House Always
Wins that's how this operates in
Washington right like McCarthy will
stick around most likely and even if he
doesn't it's not going to be Gates as
Speaker of the House and the Machine
just finds a way you got to give the
devil his due we may not like it I
certainly don't like it I don't think
any of you guys like it but it finds a
way that's why we always get into these
shutdowns frankly I would be for the
government shutting down right now and
not coming back for a couple years that
would be fine with me but that's not
what's going to happen right they
extended for 45 days and 45 days from
now we'll all be pissed about something
else and something else will happen but
don't worry zalinski will get his cash
yep and Republicans will bend over and
and bend the knee and take whatever
globalist policy that they tell them to
take and they'll implement it without
even any kind of doubt Kevin McCarthy
has been a lot different in his kind of
Reign ever since Tucker Carlson left Fox
News and I and I think really there's
something to to note here when it came
to Tucker Carlson and Fox News calling
him out that that that whole entire uh
pressure on him is totally gone and
since then we have seen a totally
different Kevin McCarthy that really has
been uh not in favor of of of the people
and ruling in a way that hasn't been
benefiting anyone the ruling Elites
isn't there something super weird
happening here because Trump backed
McCarthy Gates is a trump guy I saw the
base guys going after uh Gates today
because Trump is not because Trump
backed McCarthy so it really creates
some really strange bed fellows like the
arrows start going in some really weird
ways and then did you see Trump today
after uh after the hearing that he did
in uh where was that that was in New
York right after the hearing he
basically was like well I'm not going to
go after McCarthy because he says nice
things about me which is That's what
everyone hates about Trump but I get it
I get it he can say anything I think
they'll always love him Matt uh uh this
this this was during the fight for the
speakership in the house Trump was for
McCarthy and Matt said no and Matt said
he didn't care I think this shows Matt's
principled I I I have tremendous respect
for the work that he's doing it's about
time somebody did it but uh to be
completely honest I'll just I'll I'll
soften a bit of what you said Dave
you're right I mean the machine finds a
way you've got all these snakes and and
and Matt's trying his best I posted a
picture of Copus when he said I'm trying
to change DC and I'm not and you know
people got mad they were like what's
what's the alternative I'm like I'm not
saying he shouldn't do it I'm glad he's
doing it but he's pushing a boulder
uphill and it is a long way uphill I'm
glad I'm glad he's doing what he's doing
he's one of the most effective one of
the best politicians we have if you can
even say a politician is good but he's
pushing a boulder up well
philosophically what would you say I
mean I think if McCarthy was sitting
here he would say hey there's this giant
swamp there's this giant system I mean
I've interviewed him and talked about
this I think he would say you can maybe
get some incremental things like the
machine is so the swamp and the Deep
State it's so there's so much there and
they can almost never get anything done
right like the Democrats are just pure
evil and the Republicans are kind of
just a little less evil so I think
McCarthy's arent would be in essence it
would be hey maybe we can do a little
something spend a little bit less or get
a little money moved to the Border or
something and he I think that's really
what he's saying right now that would be
a win where basically what you're saying
is Gates is just trying he's throwing
the hell Mary knowing there is no flying
F chance that it's going to work but it
it is good if you're actually
auditioning for another job I would say
by the way I don't think it's not
necessarily just Governor I think he may
just want a a spot on network TV I don't
think he wants to be Governor I I I I
would imagine that he probably if if
this if there was further future
Ambitions Senate makes more sense
Governor brings him to the state whereas
he's in DC right now right so that's a
that's a shift I don't you wouldn't want
to take right uh well if he likes being
in Florida I mean he is a Florida guy
like he likes being in Florida why not
come home to Florida I mean DC is an
absolute disgusting cess poool of scum I
I I I I wouldn't I wouldn't immediately
say it's just about uh a a job prospect
they're trying to remove him they're
threatening to expel Matt gates for what
he's doing I wonder if this is why
Thomas Massie tweeted out this is like
yesterday um he I fear this is the quote
tweet from Thomas Massie I fear the
attempted attempting to vacate speaker
McCarthy at this juncture is a bad idea
that will lead to worse outcomes for
conservatives signed the only still
serving co-author and co-sponsor of the
motion to vacate Speaker Boehner so he
he went through this before apparently
think because mcarthy anyway uh Thomas
Massie I don't know pretty sure he did
well I think they did at the end but
they did him and Chip Roy ended up
getting a bunch of concessions that I
think now Gates is saying well you guys
aren't actually getting the concessions
at him but Massie to me Massie is the
most Libertarian anti-government guy we
have in government may you know Rand
Paul's right there too but in the house
and it's like if if that's what he's
saying there's probably he knows
something behind the scenes I wonder if
it's he's afraid of what's happening to
Gates that they're going to now turn on
Gates and he's like we don't need interp
party conflict right now because the
Democratic party is trouncing Us in
party intra party right you don't need
Gates getting any friendlier with AOC
which every now and again they kind of
dig each other but I I all appreciate I
mean they were trying to stop inside of
trading in Congress okay I'll take it
take our wins where we can yeah yeah
otherwise what they that Kevin McCarthy
has a back room deal to get funding for
Ukraine I'm I I I I I I cannot believe
that if you I I'd be willing to bet if
you went and just talked to random
people on the street should we spend
money on Ukraine they're going to say no
mostly a lot of people probably say yes
you know of course and depending on
which city you go to they're going to
have Flags everywhere they'll say yes
but I think a genuine random sabling of
a million people in this country find 70
80 90% saying no why would we do that
but of course Congress will do it why
because Congress is not beholding the
American people they're beholding to
lobbyists hey as Mitch McConnell said
the number one job of the Republican
party is to fund the Ukraine war the war
that we're also not in at some point do
you think if you're giving hundreds of
billions of dollars to fund a war you're
in a war yeah would that be a technical
way you'd say you're in a war you know
like eventually if you're fun everything
and also by the way pushing the guy with
nukes a little closer to World War II I
mean that which really is what they're
doing right like at the end of the day
you could say Russia is losing and
losing and losing which they're not by
the way but you could say that and at
the end of the day when the guy when the
is about to hit the fan he has
nukes so who really is winning and he's
and we're talking about his doorstep
yeah so it's just they've not given any
legitimate reason to us as to why we are
involved in Ukraine they've not even
tried to now Now Kevin McCarthy goes and
makes a back room deal with Democrats
ignoring the Republicans who he's
supposed to be working with to get
funding for Ukraine wasn't it am I wrong
about this they they they put together a
clean bill but it didn't have Ukraine
spending in it and they're like no
Democrats were like we refuse I mean the
fact that the Democrats have become so
clearly the war party is just such a
perfect example of when I say that the
machine always stays ahead that's how it
always stays ahead because somehow the
parties flip in front of your eyes the
Liberals become conservatives and the
conser has become liberals the machine
figures out a way to just exist and
continue do you think the people are
voting because they're afraid of Putin
or because they're just bought Oh you
mean our congressmen I don't think our
congressmen are afraid of Putin like
maybe Putin's got some dish on who's
like banging who and who's doing coke
and hookers and all that stuff but I I
think it's they they figure one way or
another they get these people basically
to betray the United States and then we
you also have to remember guys like we
have such a nation of people who are not
paying attention in any any way
whatsoever cuz they're addicted to pills
or porn or whatever or just distracted
or don't care or they're scrolling this
thing all day or playing video games all
day that it's just easy to just keep the
machine in operation it's actually not
that difficult we can all talk about it
but it's not that difficult to keep a
bunch of people stupid but I but I do
think we are seeing a generational shift
a lot of it has to do with Ron Paul
that's how you end up with people like
Matt Gates because where Ron Paul was Dr
no he's in Congress he's saying no no no
why are we doing this very few people
cared then he runs 2008 creates a
movement on the internet a lot of young
people grew up understanding and hearing
what he had to say and a lot of these
young people shouldn't have heard it at
all if the machine had its way so I do
think there's a strong possibility and
the culture war is a component of this
what the quote unquote right is in the
culture war is basically people who are
inspired by the ideas of Freedom Liberty
individuality Etc and now you're looking
at a deep State a bureaucratic State
desperate to stop a freedom move
movement of some sort toir degrees it's
pretty clear the people aren't being
represented in in congress the people
are disenfranchised people are pissed
off the price of everything is going up
and these politicians are getting richer
and richer every single year that
they're in public office when they're
supposed to be taking polit uh political
uh salaries and then but but they're
they're they're millionaires somehow how
did that happen because they're selling
you out they're selling your country out
and you were right Tim especially about
Ron Paul he started of course the
original tea party the original tea
party was hijacked but the original tea
party SED the seeds for Occupy Wall
Street Occupy Wall Street brought a lot
of people together then of course it was
also co-opted but after Occupy Wall
Street we saw a huge shift especially in
the media narratives especially in the
divide and conquer uh kind of Arena and
and now we're really reaching a point
where people are like I'm sick of
politics I hate politicians none of
these people represent me the
Republicans are just as bad as the
Democrats the Democrats are just as bad
as the Republicans it's a uni party
screwing you over and I think a lot of
people are realizing it and that's why
Kevin McCarthy I think is more popular
than ever and kthy or Matt Gates sorry
excuse me Matt Gates is is more popular
than ever they both are be honest I
apologize for that but but I got the
tweets pulled up here and that's why I'm
mixing words here but Matt Gates is more
popular than ever for a reason and and
there's a reason we reacted to this news
the way we did because it does kind of
represent a sentiment of people just
being disenfranchised and pissed off I I
think one other thing related to Gates
putting aside Governor or whether he
wants a TV host someone is going to have
to be the air parent to Maga at some
point right whether it's because of
indictments or Trump literally falls
down the stairs or or just goes out into
theet or Falls up the stairs right
exactly but whatever whatever that thing
is when when Trump is no longer involved
in this whole thing someone has to take
that thing and it seems like Gates is
basically saying hey I'll be the guy to
do that again it's kind of weird because
Trump backs McCarthy and refuses to say
anything bad about him and then the
Trump people we going after Gates today
and that that's what also makes politics
so infuriating right but Trump's just
the Avatar of the anger he's captured so
somebody's had so take the anger so when
Trump backs fouchy when Trump backs
McCarthy there's a lot of people who are
like I still think Trump's the best
betet but it means that it is not about
Trump this is the this is the this is
the thing that people didn't realize I
should say Democrats didn't realize 2016
on they kept saying Trump is doing this
Trump is causing this division like no
no no no no Trump is not the cause of he
is a symptom of the people in this
country are angry and like Michael who
was it Michael Moore he said
Donald Trump is the human Molotov
cocktail that they're going to launch
into the system and it'll feel good if
you stop there his statement was
fantastic coming from a human keg you
know but he then goes on to say for a
few days or a few weeks but then they'll
realize and they didn't realize no he
was wrong the people chose Donald Trump
because he was just an avatar
representing their anger that means as
time goes on it may not be Donald Trump
it could it could be a lot of different
people so long as you're true to what
the point is and the point is yo we want
accountability in government well there
was make America great was really cuz
you're talking about there's angry Maga
and then there's like functional Maga
and like I'm afraid that if it's the
anger that got him elected that we'll
see another anger representative in the
future maybe not even from Maga and that
things could get really bad well look
you can kill a man but you can't kill an
idea right Bri for Vendetta and that's
the idea and I think I think Gates kind
of sees that that this the Trump thing
will not exist forever how old is Trump
he's 79 78 78 78 right he's no spring
chicken again so regardless of where
this ends out whether he's president
again or anything the man will not exist
forever so Gates is seeing the writing
on the wall I mean Gates I like him a
lot too but like he is a politician so
he's in the system too he's he's not in
as a politician right now to not be a
politician actor right he's in the
politician to figure out what his next
steps are and if he sees wow there's a
movement that the leader is kind of
getting old and someone's got to take
over like he's kind of doing what's
right for him I'm not even begrudging
him that I think it's just worth noting
Victor Hugo once said nothing is more
powerful than an idea whose time time
has come and I think we're in that
particular time where there are multiple
political Paradigm shifts that are
absolutely huge that we're living
through right now it's very exciting but
also it's also very dangerous at the
time because as Ian mentioned it could
go either way yeah you could we got to
focus the magga laser on something
creative like graphine like
reindustrialization of the United States
everyone drink take a shot because if if
we don't Focus the magal laser the
Chinese Communist party will focus it or
the world economic Forum will focus it
and get people to fight each other and I
feel like that's what's been happening
for 5 years is that these people are
obviously the world is attempting to
manipulate our government and our people
and they are and I I think it's more so
you know you have that Meme where it's
uh they're trying to make us fight
amongst ourselves so that we don't
actually challenge the system and the
corrupt and uh half true that mem goes
back to Occupy Wall Street where you got
a bunch of people saying the 99% and you
know the big Bank screwed us over and
there's a rich guy in his office on the
phone he says introduce identity
politics Y what I see is they tried to
figure out a way how do you make it so
that it's no longer about the wealthy
and the poor but you make it so that the
poor people fight each other identity
politics you get a bunch of people on
the left to start attacking people based
on their race of course the right will
defend themselves who wouldn't defend
when they're being attacked namely when
they go after like white people and say
white males and all that stuff and this
creates division so it's funny to me
when we then see leftists pushing the
meme that they're making making us fight
amongst ourselves when it's like yeah
there's America a constitutional
republic that has values norms and and
rights and then there's the weird culty
Marxist garbage you're introducing you
are the scop what they're doing is the
manipulation yeah they're the Pawns in
the game they're they're the useful
idiots and they don't realize it all the
kids that were out there burning down
their neighborhoods and burning down The
Pep Boys and the target like they were
doing it to themselves and not even
realizing it but you know when you talk
about the the uni party as two as one
Florida guy to another one Florida
Florida man to another um this place
that we live in this is pretty freaking
functional there is nothing going on
here unless you guys can think of
something that I don't know about that
is not right in this state in terms of
what a functional government well do I
was uh I was driving get dinner what do
you got a gator a gator jumped out of
her River snap the beanie what there was
like 4 Ines of water in the street which
proves climate change absolutely we're
working on climate change we're we're
very close to the water here you know so
it's a little more complex we're going
to make Ian eat the bugs and then
climate change is going to be you see
you you are sarcastically illustrating
my point we can't even rain right it
rained a little today right you know
people will be like well there's a lot
of traffic in the Miami area now well
yes we did get about 300,000 new people
here and we're building incredibly fast
so I totally agree with you on the uni
party thing and that the Republicans
just blow and suck and all of those
things but in micro places in different
states and that's the beauty of
federalism it's working like this place
is hyperfunctional has brought in a
million people everyone's flourish we
have some issues there's some issues
around uh insurance right home insurance
because we have two massive we had a
category 5 hurricane Ian two day a year
ago two days and we had another one
idalia not too long ago so there's some
there's some like human issues but in
terms of the functioning of the state
and Law and Order and the the uh you
loot we shoot thing you know that
Hurrican demolished Southwest Florida
last year demolished it there were there
was no looting zero looting that
literally would not have happened there
was Skirmish outside of the Miami Heat
um Stadium but then cops came in right
away and then they booked people for
blocking traffic
immediately point there was a skirmish
or I love it when people and I saw a lot
of magga people doing this cuz they're
always going after Florida right now uh
when when it's Miami you know it's
spring break and in Miami Beach they get
thousands of people from other places
and they get real drunk at night and
they brawl in the streets and it
happened for like two nights and I saw
all these people going after Dan santis
first off the governor is not in charge
of what happens on every street in every
city every moment uh but I tweeted
something like you guys do know that if
this lasts another day Fort Lauderdale
by the way in Miami Beach Democrat mayor
some of the few Democrat Mayors in the
entire State you know he's going to get
involved and then two days later the
National Guard was there like that's
what I'm saying this place while the
while the DC version of the uni party is
deeply corrupt and backwards some places
are doing it right and it's not just
Florida I think this is the best example
of it I'm a little biased but I do
believe Florida is the Alamo it is the
the last free kind of standing place in
America that's standing up for a lot of
individual liberties a lot of Rights a
lot of uh you know just just the basic
principle of you being able to keep your
money that's a very important principle
that a lot of people don't have in
California and in New York and that's
why I think I I kind of want to go
against your point Tim a little bit I do
think a governor is more powerful than a
senator on a local level because I do
believe I say he wasn't more powerful
I'm saying we were you were talking
about Gates you were saying I don't
think he wants to be a governor I want
to be a senator yeah you you you can you
can have a lot of power in Florida or
you going have a little bitty power in
DC but DC is the whole country I would
argue a governor is way more important
than a senator mainly because of just
how much involved they are in everyday
life just how much they can make a
difference when it comes to carrying
firearms just how much they could make a
difference when it comes to tax policy
and uh I I truly do believe Matt Gates I
think would be a better Governor than a
senator and I would hope he becomes the
next governor of Florida what I'm saying
is when you're a senator or member of
Congress you can actually have an impact
on immigration and War when you're a
governor you can't kick you can't Deport
people you don't have the authority and
you can only voice your strong opin we
did send a whole bunch of people to
Martha's Vineyard which keeps them in
the country so I I do appreciate the
move because it's a sanctuary City they
say they right but the issue is while it
does
create I suppose uh notice of the issue
creates awareness yeah you can't solve
the macro ISS all it's doing though is
bringing the people in and then sending
them deeper into the you know what a
governor does do very is very important
is how they handle natural disasters I
was going to ask you guys talked about
the hurricane a little bit and and the
you loot we shoot message right off the
bat curbed it so like I think a lot of
our political instability might come
from natural disasters we might think oh
it's about people and money but like if
there's a global flood we're going to
get tens of billions of or millions of
people are going to flood the UN you
know we've already seen it on the
southern border so I think but they're
look it listen listen yes if there are
disasters and things like that in other
parts of the world but the issue is if
literally nothing happens anywhere else
in the world and we keep making the
country better they will keep saying I
want your stuff uh yeah but I anyway but
the real point is natural disasters I
think it's very important how we handle
those things and you could even call Co
a natural disaster even if it was built
by humans it that reacted as if it was a
natural plague look you know how well
Dan santis handled the Hurricanes
because they couldn't get him on
anything like the media is waiting for
the guy to literally just step in the
wrong puddle or or anything else and
idalia there was not I did not see one
article that he failed on anything you
know in during Hurricane Ian the santel
causeway it's a threemile bridge that
they built from Fort Meers to the
islands over there it was blown apart in
five different spots it would have taken
the federal government or any other
state government literally 5 to 10 years
to rebuild they had cars going over that
thing in 3 weeks I went over it and you
could not even tell the sections that
were new versus the sections that were
old because he basically walked went
there and said hey we're going to get
the best Engineers here we're cutting
all the red tape build this freaking
thing and they do it and that's so we
don't sometimes I think the thing that
disa suffers from actually is that we
don't know what to do with a competent
Governor or competent a competent
politician we just we just don't know
what to do it's like who we're doing
everything right hot damn let's talk
about this uh we have a story about
Donald Trump from Politico the crime is
against me Trump slams business fraud
trial apparently before the trial he
said that the judge was a rogue and the
prosecutor was racist I don't know what
he meant by that is it because she's
black and he's white or something but
either way what we're seeing from this
trial is absolutely Bonkers it's now
advancing I guess Ian you are saying
something that they they've dropped some
of the uh uh claims against Trump that's
what Trump said at a press conference
right after he walked out of the
courtroom he and his lawyers started
talking said that because of the statute
of limitations uh they dropped or they
they're no longer pursuing like 80% of
the case and I think that's a rough
estimate I think he made those comments
inside of a Wendy's when he was
screaming yeah I think he went to
Wendy's right after the the proceedings
and did another uh PR where he was
talking about how the is that like
Giuliani going to the Four Seasons but
it was the Four Seasons that was like uh
like a garage or something no no no he
he usually does Trump usually and he's
really good at this he does these kind
of PR stunts right after a lot of these
Court proceedings where he goes in
public places and public restaurants and
and buys everyone food and um he he buys
Goodwill and essentially that a lot a
lot of times he walks on that bill by
the way thanks for watching this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net